life throws so many things at you and
you never know what that is
Amanda Clues opened up about the death
of her husband Nick Cordero on Monday
Nick left this earth with people around
him that he loved listening to music I
don't I don't think he would have wanted
anything else so I think we gave him a
good send-off
and I'll miss him every day of my life
that's for sure Nick died Sunday morning
from kovat nineteen complications after
being hospitalized for over three months
nick is survived by amanda and their son
Elvis amanda revealed Nick had died on
Sunday in a heartfelt post next to a
photo of Nick she wrote God has another
angel in heaven now my darling husband
passed away this morning he was
surrounded in love by his family singing
and praying as he gently left this earth
there were days that I did not think I
could get on this social media and and
sing but I always felt better after I
did throughout Nick's health struggles
Amanda had encouraged people to post
videos of themselves singing along to
his song that live your life I just
wanted him to know that his dream of
becoming a rock star happened Amanda
then performed one last sing-along so in
that spirit let's do this one more time
and again guys thank you so much for all
your support
in outpouring of support for Amanda
could be seen in the comments including
sarah michelle gellar who wrote you are
a rockstar to guys that's it thank you
so much I really really appreciate it
[Music]